[DOOR OPENS]
[RINGING SOUND]
[FOOTSTEPS]
[COMPUTER SOUNDS]
[SYNTHESIZED MUSIC PLAYING]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Welcome to
the 2016 Google Play Awards.
Please welcome Purnima Kochikar,
head of apps and games BD,
Google Play.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Good evening.
How's everyone doing?
[CHEERING]
Welcome to the first
ever Google Play Awards.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
Since we announced this program
about a couple weeks ago,
there has been
incredible excitement
from the developer
community and the press
from all around the world.
This would not be possible
without you and your work.
So give yourself a
big round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
Looking back at how much we
have accomplished together
since we launched Google
Play, it's pretty amazing.
And the momentum
isn't letting up.
Your apps and games now reach
a billion users every month
through Play, and they're
driving 65 billion downloads
in 2015 alone.
Pretty amazing, isn't it?
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
Each day my team and
I have the privilege
of working with you
to help you build
successful mobile businesses.
And each day you use
the platforms and tools
we provide to create apps and
games that amaze and inspire
us.
Tonight we take the
time to celebrate you
and the great work you have
done over the last year.
Tonight we honor 10 examples
of outstanding achievement.
[APPLAUSE]
So let's get the show
started, shall we?
All right.
[PIANO MUSIC PLAYING]
[DISCO MUSIC PLAYING]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Standout Indie.
Please welcome Bob Meese,
head of games BD, Google Play.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
BOB MEESE: Hi, everyone.
This is a lot of fun.
What a great crowd tonight.
Thank you.
All right.
So indies provide fun, deep,
and meaningful experiences
spanning games of all genres.
They prove that
developers of any size
can succeed on Android.
I judged the first Google
Play indie festival last month
and it reminded me how much
I love games and the games
industry.
We're thrilled to
support this community
and it's so important to us.
We have the Indie
Corner which we recently
launched which is a dedicated
collection of indie games
that we promote
on the Play Store.
Let's look at the nominees.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Standout Indie nominees
are Alphabear, Alto's Adventure,
Fast Like a Fox, Neko Atsume
Kitty Collector, Prune.
Standout Indie.
BOB MEESE: All right.
You ready?
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
The winner of the first ever
Google Play Award is Alphabear.
[MUSIC, CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
Congratulations.
All right.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Best Use of
Google Play game services.
BOB MEESE: All right.
For the next award-- so
Google Play game services
fuel increased
competition on Google Play
that help create a great
community of gamers.
With features like
multiplayer and leaderboards,
they help keep gamers
engaged and keep
them coming back for more.
All the nominees
in this category
integrated multiple
Google Play game features
that enhance the
overall user experience.
Let's take a look the nominees.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Best Use of
Google Play game services
nominees are Sea Battle 2,
Table Tennis Touch, Tapventures,
Tower Madness 2,
Zombie Highway 2.
Best Use of Google
Play game services.
BOB MEESE: All right.
For the next one-- applause
for all the nominees.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
And the winner is
Table Tennis Touch.
[MUSIC, CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
Congrats.
There you go
[INAUDIBLE] congrats.
[CLASSICAL MUSIC PLAYING]
[CAT MEOWING]
[CURTAIN OPENS]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Best
Use of Material Design.
Please welcome Larissa Fontaine,
head of apps BD, Google Play.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
LARISSA FONTAINE:
So having recently
finished a home
improvement project,
I used even more new
apps than I usually do,
which is kind of a lot.
It was incredible,
with the adoption
of material design, how quickly
I was able to navigate and find
recommendations and ideas
in well-designed apps.
They were enjoyable,
intuitive, and helped
me find exactly what I was
looking for without having
to hunt and peck.
And it's not just
home improvement apps.
Over one million apps have
adopted material design
elements in just the last two
years since we announced them.
This year's nominees represent
first class material design
implementations across
many categories.
And the nominees are.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Best Use
of Material Design nominees
are Bring!, Fabulous,
Robinhood, Todoist, Vevo.
Best Use of Material Design.
LARISSA FONTAINE: And
the winner is Robinhood.
[MUSIC, CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
Hey.
Congratulations.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Standout Startup.
LARISSA FONTAINE:
I'm still here.
[LAUGHTER]
Similar to our focus
on indies, this year
we're putting startup
developers front and center.
And as we've talked about a
couple times over the last two
days, we've launched
an early access program
for apps that are still in
beta to connect developers
with a community
of early adopters
to get great feedback
earlier in development.
We are consistently amazed
with the incredible funnel
of fresh and unique experiences
coming from lean teams.
And this group of nominees
represent incredible startups
from across the ecosystem.
And the nominees are.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Standout
Startup nominees
are the Dubsmash, Hopper,
Musical.ly, Robinhood, Vrse.
Standout Startup.
LARISSA FONTAINE: And
the winner is Hopper.
[MUSIC, CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
Awesome.
Congratulations.
[VIDEO GAME SOUNDS]
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Best Families App.
Please welcome Ben Galbraith,
head of developer relations,
developer product group.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
BEN GALBRAITH: Last May we
launched a dedicated family
section in the Play Store.
We did this to help developers
surface their apps and games
to parents, and to
provide a unique discovery
experience based on age
and popular characters.
As the father of
eight young children--
all one wife, all one
at a time-- this section
is enormously popular
in our household.
We love these apps.
Let's take a look
at the nominees.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Best
Families App nominees
are Card Wars - Adventure Time,
LEGO Jurassic World, My Very
Hungry Caterpillar,
Thinkrolls 2, Toca Nature.
Best Families App.
BEN GALBRAITH: And the
winner is Thinkrolls 2.
[MUSIC AND APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Most Innovative.
BEN GALBRAITH: The Most
Innovative category
highlights the
apps and games that
bring the wow moments,
that demonstrate
something truly new and unique.
Now, this could come in
the form of new controls
for a game based on
the latest sensors
or it could be deep
personalization that
gives you an intimate, emotional
connection to the experience.
In whatever form it
comes, innovation
can transform something ordinary
into something immersive.
All on a mobile device that
fits in the palm of your hand.
And the nominees are.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Most Innovative
nominees are Fabulous,
Fast Like a Fox, New
York Times VR, SmartNews,
This War of Mine.
Most Innovative.
BEN GALBRAITH: And the
winner is New York Times VR.
[MUSIC, CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE]
[PHONE RINGING AND DIGITAL
TALKING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[OOHS AND AHHS]
[PADDLEBALL]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Early Adopter.
Please welcome Sameer Samat,
VP Product Management,
Google Play.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
SAMEER SAMAT: I'm only
realizing now that many of you
did not get the memo on
the appropriate dress
code for this evening's attire.
And you're forgiven, however.
But I wanted to look my best in
honor of some of the greatest
developers in the world.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
One of the favorite
parts of my job
is watching developers
take a new design
or a nascent technology and
create experiences that are
truly changing people's lives.
The apps and the
games that they create
offer a service, piece
of functionality,
or an entirely new
experience that
is truly inspiring and amazing.
Being an early adopter
is really hard.
It means challenging
the status quo.
It means pushing your team
in different directions.
These are all things
that we at Google truly
admire in this year's nominees.
Let's take a look.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Early
Adopter nominees
are Glide, Mechanic Escape,
Minecraft Story Mode,
World Around Me, Zumper.
Early Adopter.
SAMEER SAMAT: And the winner
this year in the Early Adopter
category is World Around Me.
[MUSIC, CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Go Global.
SAMEER SAMAT: Given how
popular Android devices are
around the world, we often
get asked by developers,
how do I make a successful
entrance into a new market?
And many people think
that localizing an app
just means taking the app
from one language to another.
But it's so much more than that.
For an app to feel
truly successful
in a different
country, users there
need to believe that
it was built for them.
This is all about
colors and character
choices and contextual
relevance as well as language.
It's really hard to do.
And so this year we wanted
to honor a set of developers
that exemplify what great
localization looks like.
And the nominees are.
Let's take a look.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Go Global nominees
are Dragon Ball Z Dokkan Battle,
Freeletics Bodyweight, Memrise,
Musixmatch, Pokemon
Shuffle Mobile.
Go Global.
SAMEER SAMAT: And
the winner this year
in the Go Global category,
Pokemon Shuffle Mobile.
[MUSIC, CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
[CAT MEOWING]
[DIGITAL MUSIC AND SOUNDS]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Best App.
Please welcome Jamie
Rosenberg, VP Google Play.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
JAMIE ROSENBERG: Hi, everyone.
It's incredibly humbling--
just looking out at this room,
it's incredibly
humbling, as a reminder,
to see how far our
Android developer
community has come
since we first launched
the platform back in 2008.
We're now at the final two award
categories of the night, Best
App and Best Game.
The nominees in these
categories are true examples
of the amazing work
being done by all of you
and our Android developers
all over the world.
First, the award for Best App.
Whether you're looking for
a recipe, ideas for a home
remodel, or ways to stay
informed or entertained,
the nominees in this
category make your day
more productive and more fun.
They serve their users
in different ways,
but what they all have in common
is great design, intuitive user
experience, and broad appeal.
Let's take a look at the
nominees for Best App.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Best App nominees
are BuzzFeed News, Colorfy,
Houzz, TuneIn Radio, Yummly.
Best App.
JAMIE ROSENBERG: And the winner
of the award for Best App
is Houzz.
[MUSIC, CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
Congrats.
It's heavy.
Congrats, guys.
Well done.
[DIGITAL SOUNDS]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Best Game.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
JAMIE ROSENBERG: I'll have to
try that one at home later.
So this year's
nominees for Best Game
give everyone a
reason to be a gamer.
From big screen characters
to small screen heroes,
from puzzles to
clans to battles,
these nominees connect and
delight users everywhere,
and they're also a ton of fun.
They also tend to showcase
the very best of what
an Android device can do.
So let's take a look at
the nominees for Best Game.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Best Game nominees
are Alphabear, Clash of Kings,
Clash Royale, MARVEL Future
Fight, Star Wars
Galaxy of Heroes.
Best Game.
JAMIE ROSENBERG: And the
winner of the Google Play award
for Best Game is Clash Royale.
[MUSIC, CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
What's up, man?
How are you?
Congrats.
All right.
Well done.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Please welcome back
to the stage Purnima Kochikar.
[MUSIC AND APPLAUSE]
PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: All right.
One more huge round of
applause for all the nominees
and the winners, please.
Make some noise.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
With so many amazing
apps and games,
it was an extremely
difficult task
for the panel to pick the
nominees and the winners.
Thank you for constantly pushing
the boundaries to show us
what's possible.
I hope you had a
good time tonight.
[CHEERING]
And I hope you're energized to
go out and use the new tools
and features that we announced
all through I/O to create
new apps and games.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
My team and I are
eagerly waiting
to see what you
will create next.
We are constantly
amazed, and it's
what makes our
jobs fun every day.
But first, it's time to
go out and have some fun.
Please join us for after hours
happening all around the venue.
Goodnight and thank you.
[MUSIC, CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]